[Musique]
je me nomme sa mascotte et je suis un
sixième annick je pratique le ski et le
soccer j'adore les sièges ou plus
précisément l'astronomie je suis curieux
de la nation je me pose des questions
sur tout document
ma curiosité m'a poussé à me questionner
sur la possibilité de coloniser une
autre planète comme colonisé une autre
planète
ce projet peut paraître fou mais puisque
rennes était possible je vais vous
montrer comment réaliser celui ci avant
de poursuivre qui gît nasa présente
crois que jour nous pourrons colonisé
une autre planète
si oui veuillez lever la main je
constate que la majorité des gens sont
avec moi pour ce projet mais la première
question se pose pourquoi qui vient de
planet 2 sur des raisons s'expose des
raisons scientifiques et des raisons
même temps les raisons scientifiques
sont des découvrir de nouveaux endroits
des nouveaux matériaux des nouvelles sur
nrj et plus car il était possible nous
pourrons peut-être même rencontré une
nouvelle espèce moi j'adorerais celle ci
les raisonnements terre quant à eux sont
pour la survie de l'humanité
ils sont la surpopulation elle sort
consommation et le manque de ressources
à long terme
en fait bondir les faits de ça c'est une
autre planète n'est pas sans problème
premièrement il ne voudrait beaucoup
d'argent ou que pine pourrait fournir
assez d'argent face ce projet en fait il
faudrait que ce soit un projet
international
ensuite les communications terrestres où
nous serions jusqu'à la planète terre ou
vice versa votre petit texto en fait
votre honte de messages pourraient
prendre jusqu'à plusieurs années à
parvenir à votre correspondant
ensuite où on voit comment 17e en fait
une pige au sort un peu laisser ça comme
ça y'a midi retard mais malgré tous nos
problèmes à surmonter
je crois qu'une expédition restait
possible pour une planète
cet homme d'appareil mais elle doit
contenir de luz forme liquide
la matière organique ou plutôt de la
nourriture et une source d'énergie
exploitables
pour aujourd'hui je vais sûrement pas
les deux astres possiblement à table par
être humain
commençons par câble à 1 26 f
elle se situe instance de 557 en lumière
bon ça ne paraît pas beaucoup mais
n'oubliez pas que une année lumière et
tu vois plus de 9 milliards de
kilomètres celle ci est énorme et avec
son diamètre de 14000 9,5 kg mike à plat
et un peu plus grosse que la terre
continue avec europe non pas les
continents mais plutôt une des lunes de
jupiter europe se situe à distance de
628 millions de kilomètres
c'est extrêmement qui prêche que kepler
est avec son diamètre de 3 2 628
millions des kilomètres europe et
environ 400 coups de sécateurs finissons
par le fameux vaisseau notre vaisseau il
devrait ressembler à celui ci monsieur
ça y est resté pendant un certain moment
votre corps humain subi plusieurs
changements comme la truffe la trophy la
trop fils suler globules rouges en plus
des difficultés assure fouiller dans vos
veines et vous où sont beaucoup plus
fragiles
le vaisseau et devrait ressembler à
celui ci je suis pour écrit sa propre
gravité artificielle en tendance sur
l'humain ceux ci se nomme l'effet de la
centrifugeuse
mais attention s'il tombe trop de gens
vont marocain et s'il ne tombe pas assez
vite nous aurons juste pas de gravité
en conclusion je crois fermement que
nous avons les capacités pour faire ce
projet
ce n'est qu'une question de temps mais
si notre expédition mais si notre
expédition spatiale est possible rien
n'était impossible
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]